I can hi welcome
nice glasses why you're not wearing them
well I I will put them on if it turns
out I need to refer to my notes I I was
very interested also in what you've been
doing your projects and it seems to me
that it's not just about art I noticed
that you're investigating the natural
world there in these places and and why
why have that dualism at the christensen
fund and what's important to you to
think about in terms of that and culture
we we think that one of the you know one
of the consequences of that cartesian
division was most of the kind of
problems we face in in the world today
right now and that what what we one of
the things that we as a global society
are doing are trying to put things back
together and develop a kind of a unified
understanding of the planet of diversity
and so on and so forth so that if we can
be thinking in an integrated way where
we don't separate biology and culture
and and so on and instead see them as a
more integrated whole then we're
probably going to tackle many of the
kinds of fundamental problems that we've
we have found so we tend to be more
comfortable with languages of creativity
than languages of art and so you know
our work with people that we might call
say creative practitioners they might be
a farmer say but what they're doing
playing around with you know germ plasm
or playing around with the structure of
their land might actually be in some
ways what an artist might also there's
there are elements of creativity simple
parallel elements of creativity so and
they may you know many of the farmers we
work with also turn out to be you know
musicians and Norrell
stupid but you know they've been we
don't come and look at them in this
partitioned kind of a way we try to look
at them as a whole person who's engaging
with constructing their world and
changing their world and really
deploying a creativity that builds on a
solid body of kind of experience as as
an artist would but in this case as a as
a farmer or as the manager of a sacred
forest which has an aesthetic biological
physical and ethereal component and and
they're playing with that and we're
interested with the people who the
people who can lift and manage that in a
you know holistic kind of a way this
this sort of holistic approach I've been
hearing a lot today about the science
trickling down to people or art or
science and it seems to me that there's
this problem that that we have right now
that's part of this turmoil that John is
mentioning that's something about I mean
certainly science is this epistemology
that has these functions but I wonder
about this way of living where we we
slice things up where we have art and
science and it it comes from this way or
that way and it seems to me that what
you're referring to is a different way
of grabbing a whole bunch of different
ways of knowing and just utilizing them
as a citizen or a person and you're
looking for other models maybe elsewhere
to bring back here to this kind of dual
this culture that likes to talk in
binaries and maybe binaries isn't always
so good maybe it's great for a clock but
not for us I think even you know and you
actually talk to scientists outside of a
you know in the right in in the right
kind of context you know they don't have
particularly a different view about
on creativity and so on I think that and
likewise if you talk to artists in all
of these areas there is there were kinds
of discipline and there were kinds of
learning and then there are in this
creativity I think what we haven't got
in so so actually I think what's going
on isn't is actually and what people are
feeling is actually much smarter and
much more holistic it's just we haven't
got a language to discuss it in our
institutions I think that's the problem
so you think things are better not worse
things are a little better they are
better I mean you know depends on what
time scale we're talking about but you
know things are a lot better than the
1950s you know you know yes they are
better and they're getting better but we
have to develop a new language which
enables institutions to be comfortable
we've got to get out of our entanglement
in the in the disciplines you know it's
really an 18th 19th century notion and
we've gotten ourselves fossilized in
them because of the way we structured
our universities primarily and the
university funding mechanisms and it's
really tangling us up because they're
Russian you know their rationale really
has disappeared I mean other these are
the really ideas that we have in one in
one area of the social sciences which
don't flow across all of those ideas is
it really true that we're using
different methodologies in these
different disciplines I mean first of
all we've had you know the biologists
are using what the chemists used to use
and the chemists are using what the
physicists used to but they're still
defending that no no this is physics
this is chemistry whatever all of this
is known it's obvious but we just
haven't found a way to spring out of it
we need to find a way to spring out of
it and when we do I think not only will
we find that we're even more effective
at using at using science in a more
integrated way and better able to deal
with complexity and multi-dimensional
reality but I think also will create a
society which has
a much greater capacity for self self
direction and self-awareness and I think
that'll be a good thing too and I think
artists are working on this as hard as
scientists are working on it I think
that the idea that artists are no longer
engaging in the same discourse of
scientists is also much less the case in
the copy of nature from last week that's
in my purse there's an article in there
about um do-it-yourself biologists and
there's a lot of speculation in there
about whether or not these people that
are doing this building their own labs
and you know that ken has an exhibition
about art about this too so I hope we
can talk about this do but there's this
big discussion will they ever will they
do anything meaningful well these were
these people who are in these labs do
any real science will they well they ask
the right questions
will they how will this can contribute
of course it's this you know it's lovely
that they're getting in and and it
creates good citizens and all of this
but but there's a problem maybe a
healthy skepticism I don't know but it
seems to be this creative act that looks
a lot like artists or looks a lot like
hobby yeah it looks a lot like makers of
things and our teas and one idea what do
you think about that I I think that we
will find that some of them buy because
of brilliance or good luck or whatever
we'll do the next big things and I think
that's always been the case I think that
one of the most surprising thing for me
was I was expecting to see a significant
rise in citizen science and I was
expecting them to use the web and I was
expecting that we would have much we
would be having much more intelligent
discussions about almost everything and
I thought this was a good thing because
you know I think that it's important to
take debate around ideas outside of
institutions and I'm very worried
obviously about the private sectors
control of of ideas but one of the
really striking things to me or
disappointments to me is that as yet we
haven't gotten very far on that and if
you actually look on the web for citizen
science debate you know you get into
climate change you get into all of this
kind of stuff you don't tend to get into
a debate where you know which is really
taking things forward but I think that
may that may may go you know that what
we've seen in the what we've seen in the
last decade may not may not be a portent
for the future we may we may begin to
see increasing increasing space on the
web where people are able to debate
unconstrained constrained and actually
interested more interested in truth I
think there's a couple of things
the term citizen science is kind of it
feels like a made-up thing and this is
suspect to me anyway and I think that
there may be this assumption that
everything is well first of all science
as we know it isn't really very old the
age of human experience and so perhaps
we should be a little more patient about
that but also I think there's great
reason to be optimistic about people
doing things it's just not happening
maybe where you expect it there's I know
there's a biologist working up in Oregon
or Washington and she's working in in
prisons with prisoners to do mycology in
observations and investigations because
these gentlemen have to spend a great
deal of time in isolation or in in this
incarcerated condition and and so they
make great observers of Michael a
mushroom a fungi change and
in fact as a result of things like that
these one of these people and understand
is now going on to get you know going
through the the typical academic world
of getting you know at least a
bachelor's in in biology there's another
group of people who were I think
recording certain kinds of the change in
the biological climate changing in a
rare plant up in the Oregon for us and
that's because they're people that
usually hunt them or or collect them to
to sell illegally but certain biologists
know that they have a very specific and
strong knowledge and so now there are
these kinds of collaborations and
they're beginning to ask questions now I
mean that's it's it's got to go from
sort of scientists deciding what the
important question is and this sort of
idea that I heard of trickled down to
something more osmotic maybe I don't
know well that's if you mean if you only
allow idea generation in one direction
all you can do is at a decimal point to
a measure you already wanted so you know
we do a lot of work in this area we do a
lot of work with indigenous knowledge
holders who live you know in close
proximity to you know their variables in
their world and they live in societies
where they don't think someone else is
responsible for knowing what's happening
because we live in a society where we
tend to think someone else is gonna
measure anything there's no need for us
to know what's happening someone else is
gonna tell us what the temperature is or
how much rainfall or whether something
safe to eat but they don't live in a
society like that they hold this is
responsible so you know needless to say
and you know you know you love always
you heard this a thousand times
it is unbelievably extraordinary how
closely and how skillfully people you
know with what discipline people measure
people people measure events
and know how valuable that is and how
you know I mean I I'm a scientist and
when I started to do field work on this
I was absolutely just you know just
stunned you know I reduce a massive
statistical analysis of rainfall and he
would come out within about 1% of what
all people would tell me about the dates
and times of you never say [ __ ] you know
how could this be possible so that you
know that that is that is that has been
happening but we still have a sort of a
filter where basically every time
science discovers something then you'll
hear that well and you know in here's
the backup is that locals know you know
knew it too but if locals try to say
something before that has been
discovered I mean there was a species of
fish in this African river that I worked
on once about 400 miles from the sea so
the fisherman told me that there was a
kind of a fish and they would describe
this weird thing on its stomach and I
don't know what and my this is when I
was doing my doctoral my doctoral
supervisor said this has to be mythical
what are you going on about so you know
they're telling me it's not mythical
anyway it turned out that it was a sea
fish that actually migrated upriver and
and yes it did indeed feed through her
stomach on its mouth that it would fix
under their I mean you know like there
was there's a lot out there in the world
which she doesn't seem to be very likely
at the time and sorting it all out
having being open enough to all the
different realities is quite complicated
but we need to do that because what we
have not you know what we're only now
really getting means you know to build
to build our Western science we had we
had to develop the reductive method but
now our problem was we got we've got
very good at the dimensions of the
universe that that are not the the
middle dimensions of the you know we got
really good on very tiny time frames and
very long time frames could be
predictive about that and really tiny
spatial and really massive spatial time
frames and those are the ones we probed
with us
and we found it much more difficult to
deal with them
because it was too complex the middle
timeframes understanding what happens in
a landscape well then what happens on a
tiny patch of land what happens over
generations rather than on a short
period of time but most of our problems
as a society are now in that timeframe
and that's where we're going to have to
find ways of dealing dealing with other
forms of knowledge which if have you
know proven much more they've had to be
much more concerned with those effects I
mean I'm not very interested in what
indigenous fingers might have to say at
you know 10 to the minus 5 meters times
spatial frames but I'll tell you that
they will be better than that I am on a
landscape level timeframe that's quite
some time so that's where I'm really
interested at how we can explore
methodologies for understanding that
that that those diverse complex
processes that are happening on those
spatial and temporal timeframes you know
and how do you imagine utilizing those
kinds of knowledge in in our setting I
mean I worry sometimes about sort of
just borrowing the surface of a culture
it's sort of like yeah you know
everybody's afraid of genetically
modified foods which I don't know it's
necessarily fear but you know it's like
you can't take just one thing maybe out
of a culture and plop it into another
and expect it to be like the cure for
the for our problems or can you what do
you think you don't achieve system
change by you know by planning what the
one thing if you added it was going to
have the right result that's not how
things work you have to be both more
experimental but you also have to to
think
about the whole dynamics of something so
you know the idea waiting it's all part
of a soul part of our culture you know I
mean the you know when a Western person
goes this goes to visit a sacred mount
and they'll have a spiritual experience
within the first few hours you know the
local guys say saying that we lose you
we get one of those every 20 years but
you know you guys from California are
pretty quick so you know sometimes we
think about we think that too we think
that it's possible to solve you know
incredibly complicated questions
scientifical otherwise really rather
easily and other quickly I don't I don't
think that's the case you know I've been
I've been studying one particular
society in in Africa now for 25 years
and you know I find I was majorly wrong
about something you know regularly well
what are some of those things you were
wrong about what are some of those
assumptions or things that you've
disproved for yourself well I've been
fascinated with about why the why the
big reductions in child mortality and
work you know 25 years ago I was one of
the the people who was really stunned by
the degree to which maternal education
was correlated with with declining
mortality and that still shows up in
this sample but it shows up much less
than it did 25 years ago and I'm
beginning to realize how many other
variables I wasn't seeing under the
surface so it's more complicated than
you thought everything is a little more
complicated than you thought never be
never be convinced by a statistical
correlation
so we didn't get to talk enough about
the creative process in art and its
relationship to science yes well maybe
we can talk about that a little bit my
next one
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you